so um talk i want to talk a bit about uh
memory processes real virtual memory the
distinction
and how paging works uh how actually you
can figure out
what kind of memories in your system uh
how you monitor
how a process is using the memory uh
how you can configure the system to seem
to have more memory
than there really is let's overcommit
and give you an overview of where to
find more noise where you can play
around with these things
and then if we have some time which i
don't think we will have
we can go a little bit into processor
cache use and how to optimize the
performance of your
code
um the
first thing to know is the the the
kernel doesn't work with
linear memory the memory is uh separated
into pages
you can think about it as a file cabinet
and you have all these different pages
the canon refers to every page
through the frame number this
and then an offset into the page
and so if you have uh
four gigabytes of memory that results in
one million
of these uh 4k usually 4k
pages and the the memory management unit
in the in the
the hardware can uh do some tricks with
these 4k things that we are getting to
you soon
so these 4k units are called pages
and the uh these frames
have a page frame number so from 0 to
n depending on your memory size and this
is called the physical
page frame number so if you want to
refer to physical memory
you can specify the page frame number
and an offset into the page
so maybe you are in frame 12 and offset
there is your data
and so from this these physical pages
the mmu provides a way to create virtual
memory that is process specific and
we're going to get into that
uh in a minute the common size for the
page frames
is for kilobyte on intel and it has been
that way
since the 70s or 80s
so right now we're having
sizes of terabytes of memory in systems
and this results to an extreme high
amount of these page
page frames and it's continuing to be a
problem to manage these
other architectures like ibm
and arm have much larger page sizes and
don't suffer from some of these problems
so um if you look at the diagram up
there
uh you have the the physical memory
and your first physical memory with the
page and the offset
and so what the in between there's a
page table
and the page table allows you uh to
create
a logical address a virtual address for
each process
so you're having one to n physical frame
numbers
now you're also having one to n frame
numbers for each process
and the page table allows you to
reassign that
so the virtual frame number two may be
physical page number six in the hardware
and that way since these page tables are
specific to each process
every different process can have the
same address but refer to different
sections of physical memory that allows
the operating system
to isolate the processes and make sure
they don't interfere with one another
and
that also provides security in this
system
so when the when the process
starts up these page tables are empty
and as soon as the the process runs and
begins to refer to
a memory uh the processor looks at the
page table and it says where can i which
physical frame number belongs to this
address and when the page
table is empty there's nothing there we
have a major
page fault this means now the operating
system needs to provide the data that
should be there
this can be for example a load from disk
maybe we have uh
mapped an executable or a data file
from disk to this memory location but we
haven't populated it because we do
on-demand
uh paging so this means if you access a
new page
of your binary the system will find the
the page on disk read it into memory and
then
fill up the page table so that the data
is available for the process
this is a very laborious process it's
going up behind the scenes continuously
and this provides kind of the the
dynamic way of
providing memory for that you need you
think it's all memory
but it's really not there you start with
nothing
and all only what you reference is in
there so if you have
code segments that are never being
touched they will not be in memory they
will only be on disk
and so you have a virtual
size of a process that may be much
larger
than the physical size because you've
never touched certain sections the
system has never provided physical
memory for you for these memory sections
and so despite you having maybe four
gigabytes of
space for your binary you only used a
couple of megabytes
so there can be a last distinction
between the amount of memory you are
actually using
and the memory that you think you are
using
and that affects the ability of the
operating system
to run various binaries concurrently on
your system because if you never touch
them
then the system can run multiple for
example of the four gigabyte
binaries although you'd only have four
gigabytes of memory
so each process has
this kind of a memory map
in the memory map you have the binary
where the instructions are that you
execute
there is the stack when you do a
function call it saves the prior
information and it just breaks down the
stack
there is a heap where you do dynamic
memory allocation
and there may be also uh shared
libraries in there
and stuff like that so the operators and
manages that stuff for you and provides
the address map
this address specific to each of your
processes
processes so um
then it also means that
pages can be shared in between processes
let's say two
different processes users use the same
shared library
or the same binary glc is an example
it's used by almost every process in
this system the system only needs
one physical page frame with the content
of the binary and it can then be
linked to each of the different address
spaces of the processors that are using
them
this is another way to save memory and
to allow
a system optimization and so usually
if there is a shared mapping for example
of a binary
all these mappings are read only and
this means that the processor can
enforce that if you try to do a right
operation
to a read-only page the operating system
will get control and can check what's
going on here
does this process have the right
actually to write to this page
if the process does not it can create an
error message and can avoid the process
on the other hand if the process has a
right to do so
but another process must still read the
old version
the kernel can allocate a new page
copy the page and allow modifications to
the new page
that is called copy on write which is a
typical
thing that happens frequently
because for example a process forks
this means it creates another copy of
itself
and the copy is not really being made
it's just the a new address and the new
page table is being set up for the new
process
and all the mappings are mapped read
only and the new process now can
run and as soon as it tries to write to
something the kernel will provide
additional memory to it
this is again following the concept of
on-demand memory
and which is minimizes the amount of
memory actually that your process is
is using and allows you to run much more
on a system
in terms of memory use and what you
actually have
then there are special pages for example
uh
some pages you may want to swap out so
let's say the system is getting
overloaded and now the system has to
remove mapping because there's not
enough physical memory the system will
look at okay
who's which physical pages have been
used the least
or have been have been used for a long
time the kernel will then
invalidate these mappings and make them
free and use it for different purposes
on the assumption that you won't get
back to this page soon if you get back
to this page it will give you
the same physical content in a different
page
it can do that for uh files from disks
that are read only
without a problem you can just
invalidate it and give it to another
process because you can re-read it from
disk
but let's say you have a heap page that
you have you have the navigated memory
and you have changed it and now the
kernel cannot invalidate that without
losing data
in that case the kernel creates a
a copy of the page on disk
in the swap area writes the content of
the
physical page to disk and then removes
the mapping and gives
the memory to another process that is
called swapping
the kernel keeps a memory of where to
put that thing in the page table
so if you if the process touches the
dynamically allocated memory again
the kernel will stop the process okay i
need to re-read this from my swap space
get the page back
and then you can run this means that if
you go into
swap or if you have don't have enough
memory the
performance of the system will gradually
degrade as you
overuse memory it will uh
the more you overuse memory the more
this activity will come into play
and the slower your system as a whole
will work
so it is always a judgment call on how
much of that you will allow and we'll
get to that
later so then we have the zero page
lots of memory in the system is just
simply zeros
so we have created one page that we all
know is always zero and we write protect
it
and whenever we need zeros we map the
page into
the various processes this means if you
zero for four gigabyte of memory you use
one four kilobyte page it doesn't
require too much memory
only when you actually modify the the
pages and provide something that is
non-zero into it
will the system actually allocate memory
a lot of people get very confused by
this
they okay i'm creating 100 processors
and they all allocate
five gigabytes of memory how can this be
i only have four gigabytes
because yes you only use one page and
it's all zeros when you start writing to
this uh five gigabytes of memory
then it will allocate and then the
system will come to slowly to a grand
stop
and crawl along and no longer work
um so the classical thing here is
re-data behavior so
typically let's say you want to access
data from a file that you have
mapped into memory using map so if you
do the map
the memory range is has no entries
when you first touch and try to read
data from the memory location the system
gets a page fault and oh it's not there
it's a major pay
page fault and now the system starts to
read these things from disk
and fills out the page table and once
the data is there it returns to your
program and the program continues
that is a very slow process so what
we're usually doing is we don't read one
single page
we read a lot of pages because on the
assumption that you will read
more and we need more anyways if we
don't go back and go back to the disk
and maybe move the head and which is
very expensive and cause without
slowness so we have a
technique called a reader head when you
do a single read
it reads the next 512 kilobytes of
memory
just in case you want to do the next
thing
this is pretty significant these days
because these io devices are very fast
and usually this overhead is worth it
and as time progressed this increases it
used to be much much
lower in the 80s and 90s but we have
legacy behavior here
that we have to deal with then write
data
if you modify a memory location of a
file
then the system knows okay this is now 5
hasn't been modified
but it's not on disk yet so now the
system has to manage the consistency of
the data on disk
um the system will track all the pages
that you have
written to and these are called the
dirty pages
and the dirty pages have to be cleaned
and this works by
a process that scans for pages in
neighboring range and if it finds
that there's a series of pages that have
that are dirty it creates the right
request
to disk the pages are then written to
disk in the background
and at that point the pages are clean
again
uh so that kind of
means that when you simply switch off
the system by pressing the power button
you will not have all the data or
unless the data has been written back to
disk that's why you have the command
called the sync
command the sync command makes sure that
all dirty pages are written to disk
and then you have a consistent uh dip
content on the disk
um the pages can be in memory and they
can be also be used by
oh gosh by other
okay don't do this and so let's
say you've written to a page the the
kernel puts it into a
thing called a page cache so now if you
have other
uh programs that use the same page they
will use a copy from memory not the copy
from disk
that is an optimization and so for time
being you may have the illusion
that the page has been changed on disk
although it's only in memory
so there's also a cause for confusion
because people don't see
that there must be a statement when the
page has been cleaned out to disk
only if you do a certain flush command
or a sync command can you be guaranteed
that the content is actually on disk
and that a power failure will not cause
you the loss of data
this is a lot of a lot of stuff having
has been discussed repeatedly
in database design and database uh
security and making them making them
crash from requires
some kind of thinking behavior and we
already discussed the two
different types of pages there are pages
that reflect pages from disk
where we can just validate the mapping
and assign the ear sign the page because
we have a copy on disk
and then there are anonymous pages pages
that don't have a file
that's why they're called anonymous like
the heap allocations for
dynamic data allocations for those we
must
allocate memory on a special file called
the swap device
to be able to write them out and
preserve them in case we need to
use the memory for some other purpose
then um how do you get information about
what's going on in the system
there's a special file in in the proc
file system procmininfo
which shows you the current state of
affairs what's going on
with memory um there are various other
commands as well like numa ctl free top
and the message
they all rely on the same data that is
either in program info or in this
device's
system under that you find a lot of
directories and other information that
gives you
details on system memory and system
behavior
and so if you look at the various things
that are listed here
uh you see some of the stuff that we
just talked about
the memory total is how much physical
ram you actually have in your system
then how much of a memory is actually
available right now
um then the cached means how much how
many of these these
pages in memory reflect data from the
disk
and this means they can potentially be
invalidated without too much cost
then swap cache how much action how many
of these
pages and memory actually have a spot on
the swap device so they could be
evicted and this zero kilobytes means
i've never used swap
the system doesn't even did not even
assign
a page block on the disk for all my
anonymous memory
because we never got that far and then
we have the active and the inactive
the uh system keeps these 4k pages on
either the active list it was more
recently used
or on the inactive list it hasn't been
used for a while when the system gets
shot on memory
it will remove pages from the inactive
list
from memory and give that memory to
another process that needs memory for a
different purpose
and so the pages are moving back and
forth between the active list and the
inactive list
if a page is on the inactive list and
you make a memory access
it's moved on to the active list
and then we have the active list in an
active list for a file backed
pages and for anonymous pages
we have may have some memory that is
unevictable
uh or m-logged there is a way to tell
the system
these pages never have to go out of
memory must be must stay in memory
if you said that then we can do nothing
about it
if you do too much of that then the
system cannot actually do
efficient paging anymore and the system
actually may fail
then here is the swap we actually have
about
uh two two gigabytes here of uh of total
swap
and all of that is free we've never used
it
um then there are the dirty pages there
are
48 kilobytes of pages right now in
memory that i have modified
and that are not on the disk yet if you
if this number is non-zero then you
shouldn't switch off the system
because something will be lost
so um if you want to make sure that
you've shut down the system in a good
way you can look at that number and make
type sync or something and see it's zero
okay you could switch it off in an
emergency
if you do a shutdown a regular shutdown
from the operating system it will
write back all the dirty pages first
then write back means the pages that are
have been identified as dirty and where
a command has been given to a device
please write it back but the device has
not completed that action yet
this happens usually if you have a large
copy operation
then the dirty pages come converted to
right back pages
and will stay there for a while until
the device has been successful
in writing all the data back to disk
and then continue over there we have the
anonymous pages
the mapped pages uh then there's various
administrative
stuff for the for the kernel the slab
pages
stack the kernel stack and the stuff
used for page tables
look there's about what is it 11
megabytes of page tables
this is just the pages used to map the
virtual addresses to the physical
addresses and this can be significant
depending on
how large your physical address ranges
are if you have a couple of terabytes
size process then it will use a
significant amount of page tables
and on 32-bit systems with
the special address extension system
actually cause other memory issues
uh yep okay then we have some other
stuff here like numa ctl
if you have a business system with two
different pneuma nodes
then you can inquire here what is the
topology here how much
pages are free top shows you uh
a list of the processes that are most
active and most consume the most
resources in your system
and you can see what's happening there
and maybe why the system is slow
and the message shows you the current
state of affairs
what's happening uh on terms of the
operating system messages
and at the beginning of the message you
can see also how the system detects
the memory of the system and how it
creates physical memory from these
blocks of memory defines on boot up
okay then there's a way to inspect the
[Music]
how a process uses memory we looked at i
told you about chop which is a commonly
used tool
but you can also go directly into uh the
profile system to figure out what's
going on with a certain process
so if you know the pit here's another
for example the ssd
ssh the daemon process you can just go
into this thing and
look at the status file for example
there are a lot of other files in there
as well which gives you more details
on what's actually going on there but i
think this is the most important at
least for
memory management and so you can see
vmpeak this is the largest sized
virtual memory that you've used in this
process so far
and then the current size of the virtual
memory you may have
actually mapped a huge amount of memory
and then unmapped it again so the
process was shrunk
here it wasn't shrunk so far how many of
the vm pages have been locked in memory
how many of them have been pinned
how many actually pages and memory are
being used so we have a processor that
is 65
megabyte in size virtual but it only
uses six megabytes
an actual physical memory because of all
these measures that we talked about with
the zero pages the duplication and all
the other things
this saves quite a huge amount of memory
um how many of these pages are anonymous
dynamically allocated objects how many
of these pages are actually on disk and
reflect
mostly binaries and then we have the
stack sizes how how what's this
executable size is libraries
and how much is used for the ptes which
is another measure of
how many page share pages have been used
and then there's a vm swap
which is pretty important if you see a
process getting slow
check the vm swap if there's actually
activity there going on there the
process is
slowed down because of insufficient
memory and the
operating system may have taken pages
away from this process
and there's other commands like ps and
top that actually they just inspect
these files
and present the data in a nice form to
you and there's
gazillions of tools that have been
written that copy part of these
office operations and use the same file
to present this information in various
ways
that may be convenient for one on the
other use case
then there's a very important tool
called ulimit that allows you to specify
limits on the num the amount of memory
that a process can use
uh you can specify for example here uh
how much of virtual memory can you use
here it says virtual memory is unlimited
but you can limit that
and say okay the process cannot really
map more than this kind of amount
uh you can set various
other the max memory size uh you can
limit the num and the amount of log
memory there's all sorts of things uh
you can change
scheduling characteristics the amount of
time it can use and
and things like that so this allows you
pretty detailed control about
resource limits of a process because you
don't want a process to hog a lot of
memory
you don't want the process to hog all of
your cpu time because you want
the system to maybe do other things as
well
then we're getting to the over commit
configuration i told you that it
there's the ability of the operating
system to reduce the actual
to actually use much less virtual memory
than physical memory here you can
configure what the system should do
if we have more virtual than physical
memory
and so there's this
overcome memory setting um
if you set it to zero uh the system will
allow you to overcome it you can
allocate as much virtual memory as you
want um
and there's one it the opportunities
will guess how much
is a reasonable amount of overall
allocation that should be allowed
and if that reasonable amount is over is
getting
as uh exhausted it will stop your
program with an
out of memory but it doesn't guess this
is 34 configuration on most systems
so it won't allow you to slow down the
system too much if you set it to two
uh it will over commit without limit so
you can allocate as much memory as you
want system will come to a crawl
because it will start swapping and
everything else but it will allow you to
go as far as you want
and number two is there's a special
ratio that is specified you want to
specify
how much virtual memory the system
should allow to be used
so the over commit ratio is it uses a
swap file and
it you can multiply the physical memory
by a certain ratio to come up with this
this allows you to have a detailed
specification as to how far
the system should go with the overcommit
typical configuration is zero so the
operating system is guesses if you get
out of memories without
uh any logical reason set it to one and
see if the overcommit
uh is is a problem if it's just slowing
down the system
my my experience is that setting one is
actually the best because these days we
rarely use
uh run into these problems and we really
overuse memory
and then if you want to have more knobs
to play with
here are some they are found in proxy's
vm and you can find your documentation
in
this linux documentation admin guide or
online somewhere
and you can play around with all these
things and some of the important ones i
have
highlighted here for example these dirty
things
stuff that controls when is are your
dirty pages written back
to disk there's a dirty right back 76
this specifies uh how much how long does
the system maximally wait
before it hits disk for a certain thing
let's say you don't want any
data to stay in memory for more than two
seconds before it's written back you can
say that there
and it makes a lot of sense because if
your system is idle and it keeps the
stuff in
memory and then it crashes that's bad so
but if it's
if it stays safe at least for two
seconds idle and you have two seconds
there you know everything's at least
written back to disk
then there's dirty background ratio
and this means at what percentage of
memory does the system begin
to run a background process to scan all
your processes
to slowly write stuff back on its own
so if you do copy operation or stuff
like that and it
stuff will stay in memory and usually if
it's not much then the system will
finish this copy operation and use it
will be very fast and then
when you do something else it will
slowly write the stuff onto disk
that's usually about five to ten percent
of system memory
then there's a dirty ratio this is the
the percentage
at which uh the system will start to
stop the program
to first focus on write back first
because we have so much
of a dirty pages that uh it is unsafe to
operate the system like say you
have 50 percent or 40 60 of memory
is dirty now this means the system
cannot freeze these things it must
do something with them and the
flexibility of the system is restricted
at that point uh then the system will
no longer allow you to allocate memory
or to
write stuff without writing first to
disk so you do
the right operation your program will
stop the system will
start only doing right back until the
dirty ratio is uh until less than dirty
ratio
memory is dirty
okay you can find more details on that
one in the admin guide here and there's
some big keys here
where you can find more data on this and
then some man pages
this is pretty important to get familiar
with that if you want to tune around
with the system and figure out more
about the system
uh it's without access and finding
being able to find the proper
documentation it's difficult to make
much progress here
and i can only point you to things here
but it's half an hour for the vm
for the memory right so if if i can get
you to read these things i
have had some success
and what time is it
yeah well i think we need to stop
um yes um you can reach me here
uh if you want to talk and have
questions
later i have not i this is i'm usually
available
pretty regularly and
i post most of my stuff and deal with
open source
patches and all sorts of things without
email address